hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel there are 4.9
billion social media users globally
meaning
6.49% of the global population uses
social media sounds fascinating right
well it is and as a social media
marketer you are someone who drives the
strategy and storytelling for your
company in the this video we will cover
everything you need to know about social
media marketing and strategy making so
stay tuned till the end of the video
Instagram is a social media platform
that needs no introduction with nearly 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily active users Instagram is
a platform drive with marketing
potential more than $7 billion Revenue
has been generated from Instagram mobile
and it's home to more than 2 million
advertisers
not only that marketing on Instagram has
the following advantages
too you have increased conversions
according to research more than onethird
of the people using the app have used it
to purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of
conversion you also have advanced
targeting options this is in part thanks
to Instagram's pent company Facebook
Instagram has access to just about all
advertising features offered by Facebook
ads with this you can advertise to
People based on their age location
gender interests and much more you can
also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them you'll also get a
greater understanding of what your
followers like and dislike based on
their engagement this enables you to
make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a
consumer so let's have a look at how
marketing is done on
Instagram let's start with number one
optimize your
bio your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and
engaging use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content You' be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more your bio should also
include a URL to where you want to drive
traffic to be it your Brand's website or
a page for a particular product make
sure to track this link as well to see
how much traffic it brings here's an
example of how Samsung uses its bio
effectively you can see it's a very
straightforward it's got a branded
hashtag it talks about all the services
Samsung offers there are links to other
pages and a link to the website as well
it's to the point and covers everything
you need to know about it next up at
number two we have create a Content
calendar now if you ask anyone who works
with social media one of the most
important things they'll tell you is to
have a Content
calendar a Content calendar enables you
to keep track of your posts it'll help
you plan ahead and automate the process
of publishing your posts when your
audience is most active a calendar helps
you decide what content caption hashtags
videos goes live on what day date or
time a consistent post schedule will
enable you to make the most out of
Instagram it'll also keep your audience
engaged and also give you access to
historical posts if you want to repost
your older
content next up we have number three get
greater reach with ads paid ads can
enable you to get more followers
engagement leads and
conversions the caveat here being that
you'll need to pay for it too the ad
options are pretty similar ilar to what
you have on Facebook like audience
segmentation based on likes interactions
buying habits and more you also have a
variety of AD formats to choose from
like story ads image ads video ads
collection ads and more moreover they
can also be set up from Facebook ads
manager here's an example from an ad
from body shop in which they're using a
single image ad the advertising works
because of its interesting creative and
attractive ad copy that attracts the
customer to interact with the post and
click on the link let's go to number
four have a visually consistent feed
Instagram is a platform in which people
gravitate towards aesthetically pleasing
content to authentic expressions and
diverse perspectives the objective is
that your feed needs to match with your
Brand's identity and must appeal to the
audience within your industry what works
nowadays are candid shorts muted Earthly
tones with a lowkey editing style your
content must feel down to earth and your
brand
approachable as you can see in the
images all of them have aesthetically
pleasing images and are somewhat blue or
underwater theme and that's the kind of
thing you should aim for your content
following an understandable and
interesting aesthetic depending on the
product you're trying to sell now for
number five tell a story the images
videos and stories you post need to tell
stories that can Captivate your audience
and establish a connection with them
this makes it more likely that they feel
closer to your brand and buy your
products your captions can tell stories
that can help your brand appear more
human and build deeper connections with
your
audience your content needs to align
with what your audience cares about or
solves problems they face here's an
example of how the page Patagonia talks
about forests in America each of their
posts tell stories about a different
issue that affects nature their brand on
Instagram revolves around bringing
awareness to such issues that's the kind
of stories you should tell with your
brand next up number six use the right
hashtags using the right hashtags can
make the difference between your post
showing up on the explore tab for
everyone to see and it getting lost in a
sea of
content your hashtags shouldn't be too
generic like hash New Year or hash style
since they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and Industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers research on successful hash
tags and limit yourself to less than
seven in each post the more the hashtags
in your post the more likely it seems
spammy untargeted and
unprofessional find out what and how
many hashtags your competitors use and
how you can do something
similar you could also create a hashtag
for your brand these need to be short
easily memorable and involve your brand
name in some way let's now go to number
seven take advantage of ugc ugc or user
generated content gives your followers
to further involve themselves with your
brand ugc ALS by them as well regardless
of the field your brand belongs to ugc
can be used to convert followers into
Advocates of your brand here's an
example of how Starbucks uses user
generated content and takes advantages
of Their audience to advertise their
products in this post here they're
attracting customers with an image of
happy children dressed in products sto
at Starbucks the post posted by another
user would be appreciated by the
audience and improve brand
loyalty next up number eight take
advantage of video ads most
instagrammers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising video
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to Instagram ads single video
ads that can create 60-second ads
corosal are a combination of images and
videos and Instagram stories that enable
you to combine images and videos to
create visually attractive
ads here's an example of the brand Pizza
73 using story ads to advertise their
pizzas it's successful because you're
showing off the product they are
advertising with well-shot videos and
captions now for number nine partner up
with
influencers connecting with influencers
Will enable you to connect with thought
leaders within the industry and enable
you to show off your brand to a larger
Audience by connecting with them your
brand will have greater authenticity and
Authority influencers need to be given
new tools resources and guidance to
carry out their role effectively and to
work together as
partners micro influencers are also
considered to be more affordable and
they have a closer connection with their
audience here we can see how Ralph
Lauren have collaborated with an
influencer to advertise their products
the influencer showing off the latest
Ralph Lauren has to offer this
encourages his interested followers to
check out the page and buy something for
themselves next for number 10 host
contests and giveaways contests enable
your audience to engage with your brand
with 3.5 times more likes and 64 times
the comments you can give away a product
or a service which enables you to boost
engagement and brand awareness contests
and giveaways need to be planned Brands
need to be partnered with Contest rules
need to be identified posts need to be
created and much more monitoring the
contest and then running it is also
really important you would need to track
your contest performance and promote the
results on other social media platforms
as well here's an example of a contest
run by Domino's Pizza which encourages
people to contribute their own short
stories and connect better with the
Brand number 11 take advantage of
stories and igtv stories enable you to
create a a combination of photos and
videos that disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand SE more approachable and
authentic adding links to the Instagram
stories can also help with driving
traffic to your
website igv on the other hand although
now seemingly on the decline still has a
few advantages to offer to The Savvy
marketer igtv provides you a unique
mobile friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like feature
ads and interviews another new tool they
have introduced is Instagram reels
Instagram's answer to Tik Tok Instagram
released reels through which users would
be able to upload 15sec clips and since
it released very recently it's r with
marketing
potential finally we have number 12
track and learn identify effective
hashtags visual Styles and the best
times to post doing this you you can
develop the best practices for your
brand social listening and analytics
will help you fine-tune your marketing
strategy and increase Instagram
engagement Facebook marketing is a form
of digital marketing that involves using
Facebook's advertising platform to
promote a product or service it involves
creating targeted ads that reach a
specific audience based on their
demographic interest and behavior
advertisers can choose from a range of
AD forms Ms that includes image and
video ads and can set a specific goals
for their campaign such as driving
website traffic or increasing brand
awareness Facebook also provides tools
for measuring the effectiveness of a
campaign allowing advertisers to track
metrics such as Impressions clicks and
conversions successful Facebook
marketing campaigns require careful
planning targeting and creative
execution digital marketers mainly use
Facebook ads as their core marketing
strategy to grow their business if you
are looking to be the one then simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the right choice for you
you will be benefited with a detailed
understanding of search engine
optimization content marketing web
analytics keyword management and
research website management and
optimization URL management search
psychology keyword organization and
match types keyword research Advanced ad
features and more not only these skills
but you will also learn the number of
tools like SE ranking hoot suit Facebook
Instagram LinkedIn YouTube Twitter
Google ads Keyword Planner and much more
so hurry up and find the course Link in
the description box for more details our
Learners have experienced HTH success in
their career listen to their experience
find the simply learns course reviews
Link in the description box so without
any further Ado let's start by knowing
top Facebook marketing strategy for 2023
today we're going to cover a number of
tips to help you gain a better advantage
on advertising on Facebook so let's get
right to it with tip number one and with
tip number one not all advertisements
need to sell something so remember you
have different objectives on Facebook
you can advertise an event you can
promote a customer story you can send
traffic to your website or you can get
them to download an app so it all goes
back to your objective so if we go to
Facebook and I want to create an ad
remember my first option is to create an
objective so you have awareness you have
consideration and you have conversion so
depending on what you want somebody to
do that's the objective you're going to
choose so just keep that in mind when
you're setting up your campaign on
Facebook you need to align your
objective with what you want people to
do so tip number two we want to use
Facebook Messenger for advertising so
Facebook Messenger is a feature that can
be used with advertising on Facebook and
it's a good tool it's a good practice
because it allow you to as the
advertiser to commute with individuals
directly so it's a feature that you
should take advantage of because it
allows you to quickly engage with your
target audience so that's the beauty of
leveraging Facebook Messenger with your
advertising the communication tools
available and for you to engage with
your target audience so it's great for
not only interacting but taking care of
any other objections that they have as
an as an audience or prospective client
so you can answer any concerns they have
right away so it's a lot more personal
and interactive than other forms of
advertising because you're directly
communicating with your audience tip
three use video advertisements I can't
stress this enough video is very
engaging in fact it's not only engaging
but it's very easy to use so we go to
Facebook really Facebook is telling us
for video all we need to do is have
basically a phone handy and an app and
just to be able to upload it so with
Facebook video you can really Drive
awareness and you can really Drive sales
mean you can really make some really
splashy videos on Facebook all you need
is a mobile camera so with Facebook
videos it's really very easy to create
you just got to be creative that's
really the key to videos you know
they're going to be engaging to the end
user say something do something that's
going to really grab their attention and
get them to do what you want them to do
so these are just some of the examples
you can see on Facebook and you can see
how creative advertisers are getting you
know clear call to action great video or
great imagery good prom emotional use so
there's a lot you can do with video and
really make it interactive so I can't
stress video enough as an option for
Facebook it really is one of the better
features with Facebook advertising and
really very limited use of resources all
you need is that web camera an app and
the ability to upload that video that's
really it for video advertisements so
keep in mind and the reason why I'm
harping on those video ads is they tend
to outperform your traditional Facebook
image ads and other formats like the
carousel or the presentation mode so
there's other types of formats on
Facebook video tends to give it that
extra Edge because it's very interactive
and in the form of interactivity comes
engagement so in this example you know
people are going to react they're going
to comment they're going to share the
video and that's what you want as an
Advertiser you want to grab as much
reach as possible towards your target
audience and so video will help you do
that it will help you not only engage
with the person but allow that video to
be shared and expand your reach towards
your target audience so remember video
can range from a few seconds all the way
up to 120 minutes so you're really going
to get more views regardless of how long
the video is because it's just going to
be so interactive so just keep that in
mind it doesn't have to be full on 120
Minutes it could be you know anywhere
from 1 to 5 minutes you know to me
that's probably a good range but just
know that you have leadway if you wanted
to so remember video ads always perform
better than single image ads or other
type of image ad formats on Facebook and
they also perform better when they have
subtitle support so just keep that in
mind as well because you may have you
know individuals watching the video from
you know different countries speaking
different languages say tip four when
you're placing your advertisement where
you place your advertising play an
important role in deciding how many
people come across it so Facebook offers
a number of different options to choose
from so remember you got the news feed
you got instant articles write column
you got suggested videos so you got a
lot of options at your disposal there's
lots of other options too so you can
have Facebook actually automatically
place your ads or you can specifically
tell Facebook where you want to place
your ads and that's all part of the
Facebook setup so if we go to Facebook
and then we go to create your campaign
so if we clu ad set here is where we're
going to be able to choose our placement
if we click on choose placement we'll be
able to you know be able to allow
Facebook to place it or we can edit the
placement specifically so just keep that
in mind you have a lot of different
options here again feeds inst articles
instream videos got rcom you even have
Instagram so you have a lot of options
available to you so my recommendation
and Facebook's recommendation is always
go with the auto placement but you could
specifically choose your place placement
if you want to when you're setting up
your campaign so start the advertising
on the news feed could be recommended
the news feed is where you're probably
going to get your most eyeballs most
users spend most of their time there and
it has the highest chance of grabbing
their attention so the news feed could
be a good place to start again you can
have it at autop placement and your ads
may be there as well or you can
specifically choose just the news feed
or other placements so tip four just be
careful where you place your ad it's
really important you want to place your
ad where you going to get eyeballs so
tip five Facebook ads also offer you the
option to advertise on Instagram so you
have that option available to you as I
mentioned in tip four you have the
option to advertise through stories
Carousel ads photo ads and video ads so
again that's all part of the ad setup
when you go to choose your placements
here you got Instagram feed you get
Instagram stories and again with both of
those placements on Instagram you can
work with with several different types
of ads including that Carousel ad
including that video ad so just keep
that in mind that Instagram is an option
for you take advantage of it there's a
lot more eyeballs on Instagram these
days and it plays off nicely with what
you're trying to do with Facebook so go
ahead and give it a try Okay so let's
take a quick break from the first few
tips we went over and let's take a look
at an ad so it's an ad break time so
let's take a look at this ad this is by
New Scientist and so what makes this ad
so great well there's been a lot of
shakeup in the world today about fake
news you know what is fake news so new
scientists is actually playing off of
that they're mentioning hey fake news
not in our world so they're actually
playing off of that that term fake news
and so that's an atttention Grabber so I
think that's what makes this looks so
good but this is a single image ad and
you can see here they're promoting this
ad with a promote promotion so try 12
weeks for just €36 okay so they have a
promotion in there so and you notice
they the image of the you know the
magazine they're also displaying that
hey you can look at this digitally on a
laptop a tablet or a mobile phone so you
have other options as well so they show
you that in the image which is placed on
the right side of their messaging so me
this is a good ad because of the
placement of the image the type of image
they're using the play on fake new and
the promotion that they're offering up
so this is really a good ad it's very
eye-catching and hopefully the
promotion's good enough to get you to
sign up okay so tip number six so tip
number six we want to continuously do AB
testing you want to always have this
option going for you you want to be able
to test variation a versus variation B
cuz you want to be able to find out what
works and what doesn't work with your
audience and on top of that it helps you
really put your best foot forward by
showing your best ad so by doing AB
testing you're getting feedback from the
audience and turning that feedback into
positive returns so you're then turning
your ad that does work well in front of
an audience and you're going to continue
to do that so AB testing is always a
good option so remember when you're
setting up your ad in Facebook go ahead
and choose to have your ab test set up
and when you do that you choose that
option you're going to be able to then
go in and choose what it is you want to
test with add a and then with ADD B so
you're going to again align your test
with a Facebook page you're going to
choose an ad format once you choose your
ad format then you're going to be able
to go ahead and you know put your ad in
there and then you're going to choose
your call to action so the whole idea
behind an AB test is you want to be able
to find what it is you want to test is
that going to be the call to act is it
going to be the messaging is it going to
be the ad format so there are lots of
things you can test with Facebook on AB
testing so it's all part of the ad setup
so things you can change again are the
color of the elements Imaging text the
call to action the position of the ad
there's lots of things you could test
that's all part of the Facebook setup so
the thing is you want to continuously
test that's the key continuously test
certain elements of an ad so testing can
be done initially on broader elements
and then smaller finer details like
statements in your ad copy so my advice
is when you're actually sending this up
on Facebook you know think ahead think
what it is you want to choose to test my
advice is maybe start out with a call to
action so if you're in Facebook itself
you know you have an opportunity to test
different call to action try that that's
an easy way to test and then you know
when you test the call Action once you
find out what works and doesn't work
then you can move on to something more
sophisticated like maybe the image type
or maybe trying different types of
imagery or ad types like the carousel
versus single image so start small start
easy and then work your way up tip
number seven so we want to choose an
appropriate call to action in your
advertisements that will attract
potential customers so what do we mean
well you have different call to actions
available to you you want to choose one
that aligns with your ad so for example
the simply learn ad about hey learn SEO
Works search engine optimization so if
you're trying to get somebody to you
know learn or take one of your courses
you're not asking them to actually shop
now you really want them to sign up so
that's the key we want them to sign up
so use a call to action that makes sense
tip number eight choose the Right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean so for this you can
consider you know website visits
interest it all depends on your
objective okay what is it you want
people to do do if it's you know
customers in the buying process then
that's our objectives to get conversions
then we want to move somebody over to a
product page and get them to purchase
you know if it's focusing on just
website visits then maybe it's the
objective of consideration maybe you
just want to get people to your website
to learn more about your product so
that's the whole idea behind you know
choosing uh the right you know objective
uh cuz you want to align the objective
with your ad okay so tip number nine
create lookalike audiences and I like
lookalike audience because what Facebook
does is they create an audience that's
similar to the audience you already
advertising to or customer base you
already have so in other words Facebook
already has an idea of who your audience
is you can also you know provide them
with additional information like an
email list to give them a better sense
of who your audience is and then what
Facebook does is they take that
information and they'll put your ad in
front of an audience that looks just
like the audience you already have
that's why they call it a lookalike
audience so it's a great feature by
Facebook it really allows you to reach a
target audience an audience that's very
similar to the audience you currently
have one example provide Facebook with
an email list with that email list
they're going to be able to map that
email list and be able to identify an
audience that you could Target so that's
the whole IA behind lookalike audience
it's a great feature by Facebook
definitely recommend taking advantage of
that why because it will increase the
number of people who will find your
advertisement relevant remember you're
targeting people who are similar to your
actual audience to your the people who
are already connected with your brand or
are already liking your page so if
they're similar to those people then the
chances of them engaging with you are
going to be greater so look alike
audiences tend to perform well because
you're targeting an audience as is very
similar to your actual audience tip
number 10 so use the golden Point rule
on your ad creative so what do we mean
by Golden Point rule well let's take
this ad here as an example so what we
want to do is we want to divide the
creative into nine equally size boxes so
what we want to do is draw two
horizontal lines and two vertical lines
just like a Tic Tac to a box and so
ideally what we want to do is place the
main subject of your ad in the cross
sections of the drawing lines and so
what that does is encourages the user to
place their focus on those points the
lines are just simply there as a
guidance to help you position your
messaging so that's the golden Point
rule really is we want to be able to
position our messaging accordingly so
time for another ad break so let's take
a look at another ad here on Facebook
and this one's by Blue Apron and so of
all the tips we've talked about this
particular ad takes into account a lot
of them okay so this is again they're
using multiple images in this ad here so
again what they're doing promotion
they're offering up a $30 off promotion
here and what they're asking you to do
is sign up to get that $30 off so you
could see the call to action we already
mentioned that in one of our tips the
call to action matches the ad so they're
asking to sign up they're using really
good imagery here and they're supporting
that with you know some good copy and
text so this is makes this ad so good I
mean who doesn't like good-look food or
tasty food and healthy food okay so
they're definitely taking advantage of
the imagery with a promotion and with a
good call to action and so remember we
want to AB test so blue apron is likely
testing this ad so what they could do
with this is test different imagery or
they could test a different promotion so
there's a lot they can do here on the AB
testing side so for me if I were to test
this yeah I would probably be testing
the imageries because we want to be able
to see what images get people to sign up
alternatively we can also test the offer
as well what offer is going to get
somebody to click on that sign up button
so ideally there's a lot to do here from
the ab test standpoint and the way
they've structured this ad it makes it
very easy to test so that's what makes
this ad really good is shows good
imagery has a good promotion and aligns
the CTA tip number 11 so we want to play
the product in the right hand of your
creative so the right side should
contain our product imagery so why is
that why because there's been a study
called the perceived product heaviness
and package evaluation and that states
that depending on where a product is
placed users would react differently to
it and so the study found that users
tend to react more positively when the
product is placed on the right side of
the eye creative so here you can see
countdown a Black Friday this is an
Amazon related ad and you could see the
product is basically a letter box which
is placed on the right side so it's a
Black Friday ad they didn't place the
image on the left side they Place some
on the right side because people tend to
react positively when the product image
is on the right side so keep that in
mind when you're placing your imagery
try to place it on the right side tip
number 12 don't use images that have
more than 20% text okay so you want to
use images that are clean remember that
blue apron image we looked at that was a
very clean image of food no text
overlaying the image so we want to try
and stay away from images that have text
on the overlay okay so there's no limit
to how much text you can add to your
creative but you know Facebook and
myself recommend hey the Lesser text you
have the more likely it is for your ad
to have its desired impact meaning
somebody's going to click on that ad
okay so keep that in mind let the image
do the talking for you you don't
necessarily need to overwhelm the image
with words or messages tip number 13 so
we want to use an ad creative that's
attention grabbing and is relevant for
your business so again going back to
that blue apron ad hey who doesn't like
good-look food good-look healthy food
green food well Switching gears we're
looking at a Nike ad who doesn't like a
good looking shoe here this is a good
running shoe and Nike is definitely
taking advantage of the opportunity to
place the shoe against a nice looking
background so here the image on the left
you got a nice mauve looking color the
shoe on the right on a nice red
background to kind of really play into
the color of the shoe and so that's
attention grabbing so the colors kind of
match and go with one another and it
tends to grab your attention so Nike is
doing a good job here of just not
showing an image of a shoe really what
they're doing is put the shoe is the
central focal point and supporting that
with additional color and they're really
putting the messaging kind of as the
background behind the shoe so they're
making it as tension grabbing as
possible here so Nike's done a good job
with this ad you know me personally I'm
not the biggest Nike fan when it comes
to shoes but hey this had definitely
grabbed my attention because now I could
see you know this shoe is really popping
to me we don't want to use clip art in
your act creative okay and don't use low
resolution pixelated images as well we
want to use high quality imagery so and
use images that are well lit you know
natural lighting always tends to work
well as as well so when you're doing a
placement for product whether that be
food or shoe you could see here in this
plated example they're putting it on the
Right image they're putting it in a
natural environment on a table on a
plate with some paper next to it you
know and then you could see the one on
the left it's of a person holding a box
with the image of plated on it and so to
me that's not stock imagery or clip art
you know that's an actual person holding
the product so it's real life you want
to make it as real life as possible and
as clear and quality as possible so when
you create attention grabbing ads you
know show images of people benefiting
from your product instead of just having
the product itself so that's always a
good idea in the case of Coca-Cola you
know these people are enjoying their
bottle of Coca-Cola well going back to
the Nike ad you know they could have had
a person wearing that shoe or you know
running with that shoe that could have
been an alternative for them as well so
the whole idea is just make sure your
ads are attention getting and they grab
your attention and if you're going to
use people make sure the person's
enjoying it just like on the previous
image the person hauling the Box we
could see she's got a smile on her face
and she is enjoying holding that box so
to me you want want to use people with
the images to the best of your ability
and that means use that person who's
enjoying it so that's really going to
put the product in the Forefront okay
tip 14 don't hesitate to experiment with
your advertisements creative or its copy
okay so what do we mean by that really
we want to be refreshing our text we
want to be refreshing our images okay so
if you're going to place an ad on
Facebook don't let that be the only ad
okay if you're using a single image ad
you know feel free to change out that
single image from time to time
especially if a lot of people have seen
that ad so if you're using reach as your
objective and you're trying to reach as
many people as possible just keep in
mind that if that ad is reaching the
same people over and over again it's
going to get stale and you want to be
able to update that ad so feel free to
change out the imagery changing out the
text is just as easy okay so feel free
to play around with the text even you're
not doing AB testing you can always
change out the text just to see hey if
changing out the text actually gets you
better engagement or meet your goals tip
15 plan your campaigns for the holiday
season okay so can't State this enough
you know towards you know October
November December there tends to be a
lot of holidays you know across multiple
religions okay so it's really the time
of year where people are in full ad mode
and and audiences are in full watch mode
so advertisers are really pushing ads
that time of year especially Christmas
you know and people are accepting of
that cuz they're used to it so you want
to be able to plan accordingly so if
you're doing your ads you can easily
engage with your audience if you're
aligning your ad with that time of year
so during Christmas most people are in
the mood for shopping so it's a time of
year where you can really really really
take advantage AG of increasing your
sales increasing your conversions so you
want to plan accordingly and so if
you're planning you know months in
advance you don't have to do a full year
but you know for me if I'm thinking I'm
going to do a lot of advertising during
the holiday season I'm probably going to
go out maybe once summer ends probably
August beginning of September beginning
of September seasons change a little I
might start thinking about the holiday
season and when you can plan
appropriately you can come out with
really good ads you can think about what
you want to say and so in this case you
know Target this particular ad is really
promoting Black Friday so Black Friday
is the day after Thanksgiving in the
United States and so here they're
letting you know Black Friday is here
and there's deals to be had so planning
in advance gives you an opportunity to
really really tweak your message in and
come up with some good creative ideas so
let's take another break and let's look
at another good look ad this example
we're going to look at Dell okay so Dell
I've seen their ads all over Facebook
they do a lot of different advertising
types between videos carousels and this
is a single image ad they're really
trying to do is get you over to the
storefront so you can buy one of these
goodlooking you know Dell computers okay
so you know here again they're promoting
their latest computer the Del inspiran
3000 Series all in one desktop so to
them anytime they create a new product
they're going to go ahead and put out a
new ad for that product and here they're
putting a little bit of a Different
Twist on it if you notice the ad itself
is just the image of the product there's
really no promotion here they're letting
the product image speak for itself
they're really showing you hey look how
good this computer looks you know this
is our new model and you know we got a
shop now CTA if you're interested go
ahead and click on that shop now so
they're really putting the effort into
the image itself you know they're not
offering any promotion you know no
discounts you know what you see is what
you get with the image and you click on
it you're going to go right to their
storefront so Dell does a good job of
really you know cranking out their new
products whenever they go to market so
tip 16 shorten the amount of time
between retargeting your audience so
Target people have visited your website
within the span of a month or two weeks
so retargeting is reaching out to people
who you've already engaged with so if
somebody's seen your ad or somebody's
went to your website somebody's even
purchased from you before you have the
opportunity to reach back out to that
person so how often you reach out to
that person or how long between their
initial engagement and when you retarget
them really does depend on what it is
you're selling so if you're selling a
pair of shoes if you're Nike then
chances are somebody's looking for a
pair of shoes is not going to be a long
purchase window meaning meaning they're
not going to wait 2 3 months so if I'm
Nike and somebody's seen my ad I'm
probably going to Target that person in
a short period of time for retargeting
so it really depends on your product but
you don't want to wait too long between
the time they've Eng initially engaged
and the time you retarget so it really
depends on your product you know again
if you're selling merchandise you know
retail it's probably going to be a
smaller time frame if your Dell
computers you know that's a bigger
purchase somebody's going to take their
time so you know you want to Target
people you know for their Dell computer
probably you know over a longer period
of time okay so just keep the product in
mind you don't want to wait too long you
don't want to keep it too short so you
want to find that nice balance of when
you could retarget someone okay tip
number 17 keep altering the hook of your
ad copy what do we mean by altering the
hook so here you can see couple of
different options option one you know
we're talking about hey if you're
interested in getting some dmca
certification you know this is what you
need to do option two little bit
different of a hook hey start your
journey to get your DMC CA certification
so you know just altering the way you're
trying to talk to somebody is really
what we're we're after here on tip
number 17 you have an ad especially the
text remember we always want to refresh
that copy but if you're testing it try
different hooks try different ways to
talk to people okay it always works well
when you can have different types of
messaging because people react to
different messaging so an effective
strategy would be to create multiple ads
with different Hooks and see what
performs best so this is an option for
AB testing okay you have an option to
add messaging go ahead and talk one way
in one option and then you know tweak
that messaging tweak that hook a bit in
option b and see what resonates with
people so that's a good option for AB
testing is always you know look at the
way you're going to try and you know get
somebody to convert tip number 18 okay
respond to lead ad responses as soon as
possible so remember one of your ad
formats is a lead ad okay so if you have
a lead ad basically what you're asking
somebody to do is add their name their
phone number and their email if you get
that information don't sit on it react
to it just like the messaging the
Facebook Messenger how it's almost
instantaneous think of the lead ads the
same way okay you have somebody who's
engaging with your ad by providing
information you don't want to sit on it
you want to respond as soon as possible
in fact you know when you do engage that
person let them know you're available on
Facebook Messenger so they can actually
then reach out to you via Facebook
Messenger just to expedite the
communication but when you get that
valuable information from the customer
you know respond as soon as possible
it's good customer service cuz the the
longer you take to respond the less
likely the customer will want to
continue interacting with you so there's
no real good rule of thumb here except
for do it as soon as possible okay tip
number 19 add scarcity to your
advertisements so what do we mean by
that well in this example we could see
the top 100 registrations get free
access so by putting this into your ad
copy we're hoping your prospects are
more inclined to buy your product due to
that that they're not going to be one of
the first 100 registrations okay so it
allows you to really put some sense of
urgency in the ad to get somebody to
react so that's what we mean by you know
scarcity okay so by doing so it could
affect the long-term credibility you
know we don't want to come across as
fear mongering by any means but hey if
your promotion is the first 100
registrations get free access then why
not you know go ahead and put it in
there some other examples could be you
know only 3 days left to register or
first 50 get 50% off or you know hurry
now there's only 2 days left so there's
other language you can put to play
around with the language but if you only
have certain slots available or certain
amount of days left there's nothing
wrong with putting that in the ad copy
to get people to react and so that's the
whole idea behind you know the scarcity
is you want to be able to let people
know hey there's a limited edition going
on here if you're interested go ahead
and take advantage tip number 20 keep
track of your ad relevant scores so your
ads do get scored so the score ranges
from 1 to 10 okay so what that score
does is it's an indicator to signify the
quality and engagement levels so you
know if your score is between one and
six then the ad isn't reaching the
relevant audience and your audience
isn't reacting to it however ever if
your relevant score is between 7 and 10
then your ads are reaching the
appropriate audience and you're getting
a lot of interaction so keep an eye on
that you know the lower the number that
means hey we're not get our ad's not
getting to the Right audience and if
it's not getting to the Right audience
our audience isn't going to react to it
so it all starts with making sure you're
reaching your audience with your ad when
your ad is reaching your audience and
you're doing AB testing your audience is
going to react to one of those to add so
that's always going to help your
relevance score so keep an eye on that
relevant score okay so let's take
another break here and let's take a look
at an ad here by Blue Bottle Coffee okay
so I'm a big coffee drinker myself I
frequent blue bottle in San Francisco a
lot and so here this is a nice image a
nice closeup image of coffee and I
really like this notice there's really
no call to action here okay so they're
putting their website URL the domain
bluebottle coffee.com they're saying hey
we Source great coffees we roast them to
Perfection and get them to you fresh so
I can vouch for that really putting
their brand out there okay so this is
more of a brand awareness type ad that's
their objective their objective is if
you're going to drink coffee at some
other location or with some other brand
hey take a look at ours you know we got
good coffee too we roast them pretty
good and and we make sure that you get
them fresh that's what they're trying to
do they're trying to introduce their
brand to you so this is a good example
of a brand awareness ad single image ad
they're definitely making use of the ad
the image itself you know with a nice
close-up shot of that roasted coffee so
that's what makes this ad so special
brand awareness you know the image is
telling us hey this coffee looks pretty
pretty good it looks nice and roasted it
looks pretty fresh and maybe I'll give
blue bottled coffee a try so that's why
they're putting their domain there okay
so it's a good brand awareness ad and
the hope is to convert some people over
to their brand okay so tip number 21
include emojis in your ad copy okay so
emojis we know are popular you use them
in text you use them on social media I
mean there's hundreds of emojis nowadays
that you could pick and choose from they
are really specific and and so here you
can see in the case of Simply learn hey
if you're taking a digital marketing
course for simply learn it doesn't hurt
to have some emojis support that that
message so you always got the thumbs up
it's a good Emoji you know the image of
the graduation and know that's a good
Emoji so you know you always want to
align you know really fun relevant
Emojis with your messaging it kind of
just helps it stick out a bit and people
resonate with Emojis and so it doesn't
hurt to add those emojis in your ad copy
and especially if your competition is
not using emojis you want every
Advantage you can to have your ad stick
out so emojis is a good way to get your
ad to stick out tip number 22 use UTM
parameters to your ad which can feed
into your Google analytics account and
provide tracking information so I can't
stress this enough if you're using
Google analytics to track your campaigns
then you want to use UTM parameters so
what do we mean by UTM parameters well
let me show you an example so all you
need to do is type in UTM tracking or
URL builder in Google and then you're
going to actually get to this page here
so what this does this is a tool to help
you create UTM tracking so if we're
simply learn and we want to advertise
and drive the audience to a specific
page in this case artificial
intelligence Masters program page so
this is going to be the URL but we want
to append that URL with some mutm
tracking parameters our campaign Source
parameter we're going to put Facebook CU
that's the source of what we're
advertising the medium in which we're
driving that traffic to the page from
Facebook is CPC which stands for cost
per click and then we're just going to
put campaign name AI engineer to
identify what it is that campaign is
related to so notice that the only
required parameter is campaign Source in
this case we're going to put Facebook
but we can also use campaign content if
we want to differentiate the different
ads that we have so you can use campaign
content parameter as well you don't have
to the only required parameter is
campaign Source my recommendation go all
lower case Okay and then when you're
done you have a URL that you can use in
your advertising so when somebody
actually goes to that URL notice the URL
includes the UTM tracking and then
analytics is going to be be able to pick
up that campaign from where Facebook the
medium is going to be CPC and the
campaign in this case is going to be AI
engineer and that's what you're going to
look for in Google analytics so it helps
you track your ads more closely because
if you don't use UTM tracking for
example on Facebook then analytics might
you know interpret that traffic coming
from that ad as you know organic social
so we want to be able to identify
specifically the campaign you're running
by putting in different variables for
those parameters so that's what UTM
tracking is you want to use it for all
your Facebook advertising okay so it
really helps you you know in analytics
identify how your campaign's performing
not only is it driving traffic but is
the campaign converting for you so if
you're trying to get somebody to sign up
for a class then analytics is going to
help us measure those conversions but
with UTM tracking we can bridge the gap
between how many people Facebook
delivered or drove to our site from the
ad and how many of those people actually
converted so UTM parameters help bridge
that Gap tip 23 use exclusion marketing
to improve your Facebook return on
investment by not including people who
have already taken the action desired by
you okay so this is a very key feature
here so if we've already advertised and
people have reacted to our ad and has
subscribed they have subscribed then we
don't want to Target that person again
so that's what exclusion marketing is we
want to be able to you know Target
people that we're really after so if you
know somebody's looked at our ad and did
not convert or did not go to our website
or did not download something or
whatever it is we wanted them to do then
those are the people we want to to focus
in on okay so in this case exclusion
marketing we're going to exclude people
who have subscribed in this case we're
going to retarget people meaning
advertise
again to people who have not subscribed
so that's what the exclusion marketing
feature does it helps you really hone in
on where you're targeting and
retargeting so that way you're not
hitting the same people over again and
that's only going to lead to poor
performance tip 24 track the right
metrix for your business so keep your
eye on important metrics what are those
metrics you know those are going to be
kpis kpis are key performance indicators
and kpis differentiate from metrics
because kpis are related to business
goals so track the right metrics for
your business what are the right metrics
for your business more than likely it's
going to be conversions or conversion
rate but you could be running a brand
awareness campaign just like a blue
bottle C coffee did and so if you're
running a brand awareness campaign then
maybe your kpi or metric is going to be
a click okay or click the rate how many
people people are actually reacting to
our ad okay so you always want to align
the right metric with your business okay
it's just very important that you're
measuring against the right metric if
you're not then it's going to be
misaligned in terms of how you judge the
campaign performance another set of
metrics could be reach and frequency so
reach and frequency allow us to measure
how many people saw the ad and post
engagement can determine how many users
are reacting to your ads see PC helps us
determine the cost Effectiveness or how
much we're paying for every click you
could see that information in your
Facebook ad manager for example if I go
to Facebook's ads manager here I'm
looking at some some ads that we're
running here what can I see I can see my
reach how many people I'm actually
reaching the frequency in which they're
seeing my ad notice I can see my
relevancy score I can also see my cost
per result I can see the total clicks so
I have a whole set of metrics available
to me really what I want to do is pick
and choose the metrics that are most
important to the ad I'm running okay so
if it's reach am I reaching the full
amount of people possible if I'm running
a brand awareness campaign or it could
be some other metric like conversion so
we want to be able to align the right
metric with the right ad tip 25 take
advantage of Facebook's location
tracking tool for your advertisements so
Facebook allows us to advertise up to 25
countries with different states
provinces cities districts and zip cods
so we can really hone in location wise
on where we want to Target so Facebook
allows us to do that so basically it
could be somebody in a particular area
or people who have been recently been
there or traveling to that location or
actually lived there so really you can
hone in on a specific location based on
certain set of criteria so with this you
could take your marketing to the next
level by approaching your competitors uh
customers by offering them better
discounts so that's the whole idea
targeting your advertising on a specific
location and then knowing that your
competitors are there you can really put
out some really good ads with some
really good offers to really convert
some of those people in that audience
okay let's take a a look at another ad
okay so grammarly this is an ad that
they've uh put out there and again you
notice there's no real true call to
action associated with the single image
ad here it's all about messaging here
they're saying hey download it free
today okay and so it's a browser
extension that they're promoting and
really they're trying to get you to
identify or identify with this
particular brand that offers a specific
product so they do have a promotion in
there it's brand awareness hey your life
is about to change I mean the messaging
is pretty you know matter of fact
they're trying to get you to hey I need
this in my browser as an extension so
for me this ad is all about the
messaging here okay so with grammarly
you know if you're in Gmail you're in
word you're in Outlook they got you
covered by using their browser expansion
it's free and by using it it's going to
make your life a lot easier so for me
the ad works from a messaging standpoint
not really big on the imagery but it's
really about this is who we are and we
can really rock your world if you use
this browser extension so they're really
putting a lot of emphasis on the
messaging so for me anytime somebody
says my life is about to change that
they've gotten my
attention staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here